the Quran says that Allah revealed the
Torah and the gospel Surah 3: 3 to 4 it
is he Allah who has sent down the book
The Quran to you Muhammad with truth
confirming what came before it and he
sent down the torat Torah and the inil
gospel a four time as a guidance to
mankind so Allah sent down the Torah and
the gospel as a guidance to mankind good
to know because I'm part of mankind and
I love being guided so I open the gospel
and I find that it contradicts the Quran
on basic teachings about Jesus for
instance in Mark 9:31 Jesus tells his
followers the son of man is going to be
delivered into the hands of men and they
will kill him and when he is killed
after 3 days he will rise in Mark 10:45
Jesus says for even the son of man came
not to be served but to serve and to
give his life as a ransom for many most
Muslims are convinced that these and
many other verses in the gospel
contradict what the Quran says in Surah
4 verse
157 that they said in boast they here
are Jews that they said in boast we
killed Christ Jesus the son of Mary the
Apostle of God but they killed him not
nor crucified him but so it was made to
appear to them and those who differ
therein are full of doubts with no
certain knowledge but only conjecture to
follow for of assurity they killed him
not so Allah says he revealed the gospel
but Muslims insist that the gospel we
have now
contradicts the
Quran what conclusion are we supposed to
draw that Allah and Muhammad didn't know
what they were talking about no we're
supposed to conclude that the gospel has
been
corrupted but concluding that the gospel
has been corrupted raises some obvious
questions who corrupted the gospel when
was the Gospel corrupted where was the
Gospel corrupted how was the Gospel
corrupted why was the Gospel corrupted
you can ask 20 different Muslim Scholars
these questions and you'll get 20
different sets of answers and the reason
you'll get 20 different sets of answers
from 20 different Muslim Scholars is
that none of these Muslim Scholars goes
to the Quran to find the answers you see
according to the Quran no one can change
Allah's words Surah 6: 114 to
115 shall I then seek a judge other than
Allah and he it is who has revealed to
you the book which is made plain and
Those whom we have given the book know
that it is revealed by your Lord with
truth therefore you should not be of the
disputers and the word of your lord has
been accomplished truly and justly there
is none who can change his words and he
is the hearing the knowing Surah 18: 27
and recite what has been revealed to you
of the book of your lord there is none
who can alter his words and you shall
not find any Refuge besides him so in
the Quran Allah claims that no one can
change his words that's why Muslim
Scholars don't go to the Quran to find
out who changed Allah's words in the
gospel they have to go to their own
imaginations and they end up saying that
the Apostle Paul corrupted the gospel or
that Christians at the Council of NAA
corrupted the gospel and so on and so on
but I'm here to help What Muslim
Scholars are missing is that if you
ignore what Allah says about no one
being able to change his words and you
decide contrary to what Allah clearly
says that the gospel was
corrupted then the Quran does tell you
who corrupted it let me say that again
the Quran States repeatedly that no one
can change Allah's words but if you
decide in spite of what Allah says that
the gospel was in fact
corrupted the Quran tells you exactly
who corrupted it the Quran gives us the
answer Muslim Scholars simply ignore the
quran's answer to the question who
corrupted the
gospel and that's where I come in I'm
going to show you right now who
corrupted The Gospel According to the
Quran to solve this mystery we'll go
through seven facts seven facts that
point to one unavoidable
conclusion here are the facts fact
number one the Quran states that Jesus
was a messenger of Allah and a prophet
of Islam Surah 19: 23-33 tells us that
Jesus began preaching Islamic theology
as a baby and Surah
42:13 says that Jesus preached the same
message as Noah Abraham Moses and
Muhammad fact number two the Quran
states that Jesus won number of
followers who were Muslims so Jesus
spent his entire life preaching Islam
and he was successful Surah 3:52 and
Surah 5: 111 say that his followers
converted to
Islam fact number three in the Quran
Allah promises Jesus that his followers
will be superior to unbelievers until
the day of Resurrection Surah 3:55
behold God said oh Jesus I will take
thee and raise thee to myself and clear
thee of the falsehoods of those who
blaspheme I will make those who follow
thee Superior to those who reject Faith
to the day of Resurrection then shall ye
all return unto me and I will judge
between you of the matters wherein ye
dispute since the day of Resurrection
hasn't arrived yet Allah's promise is
still still in effect fact number four
if there were any first century Jews who
converted to Islam due to Jesus
preaching they didn't last very long we
have a lot of historical information
about jesus' disciples but we have no
evidence at all that any of them
believed anything remotely resembling
Islam the disciples we have records of
proclaimed jesus' death resurrection and
deity
so if Jesus had Muslim followers as the
Quran claims they were so insignificant
and inconsequential that we have no
record of them even existing they must
have somehow been replaced very early on
and then faded from memory
completely fact number five according to
mainstream Islam Allah in Surah 4 verse
157 used the power of Illusion to
deceive people and to convince them that
Jesus died on the cross history shows
that Jesus early followers became
convinced that he died on the cross and
rose from the dead now according to
mainstream Orthodox Islam where did they
get the idea that Jesus died on the
cross they got the idea from Allah Who
tricked people into believing that Jesus
was crucified Allah miraculously
disguised someone else and made him look
like Jesus
then this other person was crucified but
Allah through the power of Illusion and
deception made people think that it was
Jesus so when we open the gospel that we
have and we read about Jesus dying on
the cross this belief didn't come from
the Apostle Paul it didn't come from
Christian leaders at the Council of NAA
it came from
Allah fact number six the Quran states
that Allah helped spread
Christianity once Allah had deceived
countless people tricking them into
believing that Jesus died on the cross
he worked diligently to help Christians
spread their message Surah
61:4 oh you who believe be helpers in
the cause of Allah as Issa son of miam
Jesus Son of Mary said to his disciples
who are my helpers in the cause of of
Allah the disciples said we are helpers
in the cause of Allah so a party of the
children of Israel believed and another
party disbelieved then we aided those
who believed against their enemy and
they became
uppermost this verse tells us that Allah
helped Jesus followers against the Jews
who rejected him and that these
followers eventually with the help of
Allah became a
most the only Christians who ever became
uppermost over anyone were Christians
who believed in jesus' death
resurrection and deity all of which are
false doctrines according to mainstream
Orthodox
Islam so if these Christians became
uppermost through the power of Allah we
can only conclude that Allah helped
spread a corrupt
message fact number seven the the Quran
affirms the inspiration preservation and
authority of the Christian scriptures in
Surah 7: 157 Allah refers to those who
follow the Apostle Prophet the Umi whom
they find written down with them in the
torat and the
injil this is about Jews and Christians
supposedly reading about Muhammad in the
Torah and the gospel which are written
down with us in Surah 5:47 Allah says
let the people of the Gospel judge by
what God hath revealed therein if any do
fail to judge by the light of what God
hath revealed they are no better than
those who
Rebel why would Allah command us to
judge by the gospel if he knows we have
a corrupt
gospel 5: 68 Allah tells Muhammad to say
to Jews and Christians
oh people of the book ye have no ground
to stand upon unless you stand fast by
the law the gospel and all the
Revelation that has come to you from
your
lord how can we stand fast by the gospel
if we don't have the
gospel these and many other Quran
passages assume that we still have the
inspired preserved authoritative
gospel so Allah revealed the gospel but
the gospel we have says that Jesus died
on the cross which according to our
Muslim friends contradicts the
Quran and they tell us that the gospel
must have been corrupted because it
contradicts the
Quran fine who corrupted it
then don't blame the Apostle
Paul don't blame Christians at all Blame
A
law if Muslims want to believe that the
gospel was corrupted they have to
believe that Allah is the one who
corrupted it and now we have a few
questions for our Muslim
friends one why would Allah corrupt
Jesus message and Destroy Everything
Jesus had worked so hard to
accomplish two why did Allah tell Jesus
that his followers would be superior to
unbelievers until the day of
Resurrection didn't Allah know that he
was about to corrupt Christianity by
tricking people into believing that
Jesus died on the
cross three if the gospel was revealed
by Allah as the Quran claims why didn't
Allah preserve his message instead of
corrupting it for once the gospel had
been corrupted by Allah La why did Allah
help Christians spread this corrupt
gospel instead of correcting them five
if the gospel was corrupted in the first
century by Allah himself why did Allah
command the Christians of Muhammad's
time to judge by this corrupt
book six if Allah deceives people who
follow His prophets as he deceived the
followers of Jesus
how do Muslims know that he isn't
deceiving them right
now seven since Jesus message was
corrupted by Allah what did Jesus
ultimately accomplish according to
Islam his followers ended up preaching a
false message all thanks to
Allah putting all of this together we've
solved the mystery and we now know who
corrupted the the gospel when he
corrupted the gospel how he corrupted
the gospel and why he corrupted the
gospel here's what happened Allah sent
Jesus to the children of Israel and
Jesus thanks to his powerful preaching
and astounding Miracles won a number of
converts who were Muslims Allah decided
to take Jesus away but he promised Jesus
that his followers would be superior to
unbelievers until the day of
Resurrection sadly Allah soon forgot
about that promise and he tricked Jesus
disciples into believing that he died on
the cross ultimately giving rise to
Christianity and to a corrupt
gospel then Allah forgot that he
corrupted the gospel and he helped
Christians spread their message until
they became uppermost over those who
rejected
Jesus finally Allah revealed the Quran
but by that time Allah didn't remember
much of what happened so he just kept
bragging about no one being able to
change his words and he kept telling
Christians to judge by the gospel that
we still have which was corrupted
tragically by Allah
himself the only conclusion our Muslim
friends can draw from all this is that
Allah has been suffering from dementia
for a long long time he tried but he
just can't remember things that he says
or does or promises or
corrupts if our Muslim friends want to
worship a God who isn't suffering from
dementia and who isn't a cosmic
trickster who deceives people and
undermines the work of his own prophets
and accidentally starts false
religions they'll need to look somewhere
other than
Islam if you'd like to see an even
bigger problem for Islam be sure to
watch my video what the Quran really
says about the gospel where I go through
every single verse in the Quran that so
much as mentions the
gospel spoiler alert there isn't a
single verse anywhere in the Quran that
agrees with What Muslim Scholars say
about the
gospel why is that
[Music]